[SPEAKER_00]: Président du groupe de la Banque africaine du développement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Madame la ministre assistante et directrice régionale pour l'Afrique du programme de développement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Madame la représentante de l'organisation de la préparation et du développement économique du CEE.
[SPEAKER_00]: Excellences, Mesdames et Messieurs les ambassadeurs et membres du corps diplomatique, Mesdames et Messieurs les représentants des institutions financières internationales, Madame la représentante, secrétaire générale de la Commission économique africaine, du système des Nations Unies, Mesdames et Messieurs les responsables des organisations internationales et régionales, Mesdames et Messieurs les économistes en chef
[SPEAKER_00]: les chercheurs, les universitaires, les représentants du secteur privé et de la société civile, chers amis des médias, distingués invités, mesdames et messieurs.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est pour moi un immense honneur de prendre la parole ce matin, à l'occasion de cette cérémonie d'ouverture de la Conférence économique africaine CEA 2026.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je voudrais, avant tout propos, vous adresser
[SPEAKER_00]: Au nom de Son Excellence Monsieur Alassane Ouattara, Président de la République, le traditionnel Aquaba, une aquabienne bienvenue, symbole de la totalité ivoirienne et de notre attachement, valide ouverture du dialogue et de fraternité qui fonde la coopération entre les deux.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je voudrais maintenant exprimer
[SPEAKER_00]: toute ma gratitude au Dr Sidi Oukta, président du groupe de la Banque africaine de développement, pour sa constance, la qualité et l'agricité du partenariat qui lie la Côte d'Ivoire et le groupe de la Banque africaine de développement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et le salut également de cette initiative heureuse de réunir dans ce cadre les économistes et chercheurs du monde et les acteurs du développement autour d'une problématique
[SPEAKER_00]: ce qui nous concerne collectivement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je voudrais exprimer toute ma reconnaissance au CIE, représenté par Mme Aouima Eziatour, directrice rénale du CIE pour l'Afrique, et également toute ma reconnaissance à l'organisation de la coopération et du développement économique de l'OCDE et l'organisation de cette importante rencontre annuelle avec le CIE, la Commission économique africaine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je voudrais saisir l'occasion de cette cérémonie de féliciter et encourager l'ensemble des économistes en chef des institutions de développement et de finances et des économistes en chef africains pour leurs idées de production scientifique permettant d'orienter la stratégie macroéconomique et de façonner la politique publique en vue de la transformation économique et sociale de nos pays.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je voudrais en faire brecher à chacun de vous une salueuse salutation pour votre présence remarquable à cette cérémonie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Distingués invités, Mesdames et Messieurs, Comme vous le savez, la Conférence écologique africaine représente une plateforme d'échange intellectuel, de dialogue politique et de collaboration entre acteurs politiques, universitaires et sociétés civiles sur des questions et politiques de développement en Asie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cela est bien rappelé, elle a été lancée en 2006 par la Banque africaine de développement, qui résonne plus tard par des institutions sœurs, telles que la Commission économique des Nations Unies pour l'Afrique et le Programme des Nations Unies pour le Développement du Pays.
[SPEAKER_00]: L'emploi en mission de promouvoir la recherche économique sur le continent, de critiquer dans tous les cas ces mesures, les études économiques, de renforcer les capacités d'analyse des enjeux économiques africains,
[SPEAKER_00]: et de formuler des réponses adaptées au contexte africain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cette rencontre se tient chaque année pour débattre des grands enjeux de développement sur le continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cette année, la Conférence économique africaine se penche sur un thème d'une actualité et d'une pertinence particulière, à savoir renforcer le rôle géopolitique et la résilience commerciale de l'Afrique dans un monde multipolaire.
[SPEAKER_00]: En effet, ce thème nous invite tous
[SPEAKER_00]: à une réflexion approfondie sur la plage de notre continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dans un monde mondial en pleine récomposition, et sur les médias dont on dispose, l'Afrique pourrait affirmer sa voie de consolider ses échanges en action face aux mutations géopolitiques actuelles.
[SPEAKER_00]: De fait, le monde connaît aujourd'hui de profondes mutations marquées par les tensions géopolitiques existantes, des perturbations des chaînes d'approvisionnement mondiales,
[SPEAKER_00]: les pressions inflationnistes, les effets de plus en plus prégnants, les changements climatiques, ainsi que les transformations rapides sortées par les révolutions technologiques et libérales.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ces révolutions rédessinent progressivement une similitude de puissance économique et implorent à l'Afrique de repenser son positionnement de stratégie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Face à ces défis, l'Afrique ne se peut plus se contenter d'être un cercle réservoir de matières privées,
[SPEAKER_00]: Elle doit s'affirmer comme un acteur majeur d'échelle des valeurs mondiales, un poids de croissance, d'innovation, d'industrialisation et capable de défendre ses intérêts au sein de la gouvernance économique internationale.
[SPEAKER_00]: Notre continent dispose à cet effet d'un fonds considérable, une population jeune, des ressources naturelles stratégiques et un potentiel agricole exceptionnel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ainsi, une coopération subtile, renforcée et une multipolarité de croissance ouvrent de nouvelles perspectives pour une action collective africaine.
[SPEAKER_00]: En outre, les initiatives telles que la zone de vie d'échange continentale africaine, la ZNEGA, les négociations climatiques menées par l'Union africaine, ainsi que les alliances au sein des BRICS et du G20, offrent autant de moyens de rééquilibrer les opinions
[SPEAKER_00]: et de faire progresser la solidarité de notre continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mes seigneurs invités, mesdames et messieurs, ces réflexions sur le rôle géopolitique et la résilience commerciale de notre continent trouvent pour la Côte d'Ivoire une tradition concrète et une résonance particulière.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fond de son poids économique régional et de sa stabilité, notre pays entend renforcer son propre rôle géopolitique
[SPEAKER_00]: et sa résilience commerciale à travers la mise en oeuvre de son Plan National de Développement 2026-2030 dont la vision est de bâtir une grande nation stable, ambitieuse et solidaire.
[SPEAKER_00]: La mise en oeuvre de ce plan permettra de réaliser l'ambition de lisser notre pays au rang des économies à revenus intermédiaires et la France supérieure à l'horizon 2030.
[SPEAKER_00]: A travers le PND 2026-2030,
[SPEAKER_00]: Notre pays en sent poursuivre résolument sa transformation économique tout en relevant plusieurs défis majeurs d'une condition de maintien d'une croissance durable, inclusive et résiliente, seule à même de nous permettre d'accélérer l'industrialisation, d'affirmer notre voie et de consolider notre mission dans les échanges commerciaux régionaux et mondiaux.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cette ambition requiert de relever le défi du financement du développement,
[SPEAKER_00]: par une mobilisation accrue des ressources domestiques, le renforcement des partenariats publics privés, l'approfondissement des marchés financiers et le recours à des mécanismes innovants de financement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dans ce cadre, le groupe consultatif du financement, qui est maintenant le deuxième fonds de l'Université 2030, organisé avec l'ICF, par le gouvernement ivoirien, sous la présidence du Président M. Alassane Nassara,
[SPEAKER_00]: le président de la République de Côte d'Ivoire, le 8 et 9 juillet 2016 à Abidjan, avec une mobilisation exceptionnelle de 80 milliards de dollars US, soit environ 47 820 milliards de francs CFA, constitue une administration éloquente des moyens que vous deviez nous donner pour la réalisation de vos ambitions.
[SPEAKER_00]: L'objectif de vous donner encore une fois à remercier le président du but de la Banque mondiale, de la Banque africaine de développement,
[SPEAKER_00]: Dr Sidi Ouska, pour son implication personnelle et la contribution notable du groupe de la Banque africaine de développement et de la NAFA dans le succès de cet événement, nous l'applaudissons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mesdames et Messieurs, notre continent peut-il réaliser ses ambitions sans renforcer son rôle géopolitique ?
[SPEAKER_00]: et sa résilience commerciale dans un contexte géo-économique de plus en plus fragmenté.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cette question, puisque l'actualité nous interpelle tous, de la richesse d'idées à la formulation des effectifs politiques et économiques en matière de productionnement géopolitique et de résilience commerciale, l'a fait place de grand espoir dans les délibérations de cette conférence, car c'est précisément ici, dans la confrontation des expériences nationales,
[SPEAKER_00]: Les travaux universitaires et le rendez-vous de la société civile peuvent émerger les idées les plus pertinentes pour éclairer nos décisions et nourrir nos politiques politiques.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous formons donc le vœu que les échanges des procédures soient à la hauteur des attentes de notre continent et qu'ils débouchent sur des recommandations concrètes susceptibles d'inspirer le gouvernement, les institutions régionales et nos partenaires de développement dans la conduite de nos réformes.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est tout le sens de cette conférence économique africaine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Transformer la réflexion en action et l'ambition en résultats tangibles pour le peuple africain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Avant de clore mon propos, je voudrais une fois encore saluer la qualité de la mobilisation qu'on trouve éternellement et souhaiter de plus que des chances de bien succès à la conférence économique africaine 2026.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est dans cette loi d'espoir que je voudrais clore mon propos
[SPEAKER_00]: et déclarer ouverte la Conférence économique africaine de l'université sur le thème « Renforcer le rôle géopolitique et la résilience commerciale de l'Afrique dans un monde mixte et polaire ».
[SPEAKER_00]: Je vous remercie.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merci à vous, c'était un plaisir.